so we sat down with one of the greatest
figures in American Sports Keith
Hernandez formerly of the Cardinals and
the Mets
had an amazing career as a first baseman
won two World Series titles but he was
really the kind of athlete that you
don't see today here's a man who smokes
cigarettes in The Dugout played some of
his games hungover and we asked him
because we couldn't resist how did you
do that how did you play at that high a
level while living the life you were
here's part of the conversation from
Tucker Carlson today
to read these stories about baseball
players tearing it up at night and then
playing the next day how do people play
at a high level with a hangover
you can't do it make a habit of it yeah
I bet you can't catch up to you Chicago
was the place Wrigley Field one of the
great things about Wrigley Field was
that it's the same ballpark that when
Ruth made the point yeah the home run so
you're in that Clubhouse it was this
tiny Clubhouse
tiny and you had to walk up the stairs
and over the people you could see the
people and they throw beers at you it
was just fun it was great fun I loved
Wrigley but when you sat in your locker
you go gosh darn Babe Ruth Lou Gehrig
sat here yeah you know Stan Musial
you know all the greats and here I am in
the same Locker as them
but getting back to your point
Russian division you can go into a bar
in Russian division at 11 o'clock and
it's empty you go one o'clock it's
packed and it would go to four now if
you stayed out to four
don't don't go to bed don't try to sleep
just stay up I did it three times in my
career just I because I had to do it
and and
I got out the first base and I said Lord
please no ground balls today no no
templates I promise I'll never do it
again
how'd you play
um I don't remember I did good when I
was tired or if I had I focused more if
the say I had a headache or for whatever
reason
I focused more I can't let your team
down
it's a team game I can't I can't in my
right mind go out in the field
because I'm tired or I've had too many
uh hungover and I'm holding the runner
on and I gotta come off the bat with the
pitch
and if I sluff it
and don't do that extra step and the
ball Gets By Me in the Outfield and it's
first and third I've let that my team
down that pitcher I couldn't do it
so I bore down more when I was sick
uh or if I had a few too many beers and
you never missed a game I from being
hungover oh God no heck no
no way
that's pretty impressive
no it's not no
you can't let your teammates down
but at least get to sleep till noon I
slept under my schedule even if I'd just
say it's a night game and say I uh the
normal would have been Hotel bar until
one o'clock 1 30 or go to my room go to
sleep I wouldn't wake up to 12 noon that
was my schedule night games yeah you
know I would call room service coffee
Danish and I'd turn on ABC and watch all
my children
you watched all my children on the road
yes
the religiously my whole my whole career
no way yes
you're watching soap operas in your
hotel room just that one
watching soap operas on the road you
learn something every time baseball
Legend Keith Hernandez now on Fox Nation
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else